양자 정보와 계산 이해하기에 다시 오신 걸 환영해요. 저는 John Watrous이고 교육 분야 기술 총괄이에요.
IBM Quantum에서 일하고 있어요. 이번이 시리즈의 아홉 번째 수업이고, 세 번째 단원의 첫 번째 수업이에요. 세 번째 단원은 양자 정보의 일반적인
공식화에 관한 내용이에요. 지금까지는 양자 정보의 단순화된 공식화를 사용해 왔는데요.
그 공식화에서 양자 상태는 유클리드 노름이 1인 복소 벡터로 표현돼요.
이와 대조적으로, 양자 정보의 일반적인 공식화에서는 양자 상태가
밀도 행렬이라고 하는 특정 유형의 행렬로 표현돼요. 이 단원의 첫 번째 수업은 밀도 행렬에 초점을 맞추고 있어요.
수업이 진행되면서 밀도 행렬이 무엇인지, 어떻게 작동하는지 알아볼 거예요. 밀도 행렬은 정말
유용하고 다양한 장점이 있는데, 그것도 다룰 거예요. 밀도 행렬은 양자 상태 벡터로 표현할 수 있는 것보다
더 넓은 범위의 상태를 표현할 수 있어요. 예를 들어, 노이즈에 영향을 받은 시스템의 상태나 양자 상태의 무작위
선택도 포함할 수 있어요. 또한 Bloch 구도 살펴볼 텐데, qubit 상태를 아주 멋지고
단순하게 기하학적으로 생각할 수 있는 방법을 제공해 줘요. 그리고 그게 밀도 행렬과 어떻게 연결되는지도 볼 거예요.
Pauli 행렬을 통해 꽤 놀라운 방식으로 연결되거든요. 마지막으로 복합 시스템에서의 밀도 행렬을 다룰 거예요.
특히, 다른 시스템과 연관되어 있더라도 고립된 시스템의 양자 상태를 어떻게 설명할 수 있는지 볼 거예요.
다른 시스템과 연관되어 있다는 건 다른 시스템과 얽혀 있을 가능성도 포함해요. 이건 중요한 부분이에요.
그리고 양자 정보의 단순화된 공식화에서는 쉽게 할 수 없는 것이기도 해요. 수업의 개요를 말씀드릴게요.
먼저 관련 정의와 몇 가지 예시를 포함한 밀도 행렬의 기초부터 시작할 거예요.
그리고 밀도 행렬이 양자 상태 벡터와 어떻게 연결되는지도 이야기할 거예요. 그 다음에는 밀도 행렬의 볼록 조합, 즉
밀도 행렬의 가중 평균을 취하면 어떻게 되는지 이야기할 거예요. 특정
완전히 혼합된 상태라는 예시부터 시작할 거예요. 고전적인 확률 상태가 밀도 행렬의
특수한 경우로 어떻게 볼 수 있는지도 다룰 거예요. 그리고 선형 대수의 스펙트럼 정리가 이
맥락에서 어떻게 작용하는지도 이야기할 거예요. 수업의 세 번째 부분은 Bloch 구에 관한 것으로,
수업 시작 부분에서 언급했듯이 단일 qubit 상태를 기하학적으로 볼 수 있게 해줘요. 수업의 네 번째 부분에서는 다중
시스템에서 밀도 행렬이 어떻게 작동하는지 이야기할 거예요. 얽힌 상태를 포함한 다양한 종류의 곱 상태와 상관 상태를 논의할 거예요.
그리고 복합 시스템의 고립된 부분의 상태를 밀도 행렬로 설명하는 축소 상태의 개념도 다룰 거예요.
이것은 부분 트레이스라는 연산을 사용해 계산할 수 있어요. 수업의 기술적인 내용으로 들어가기 전에,
밀도 행렬 사용의 동기를 설명하는 데 잠깐 시간을 내는 게 좋을 것 같아요. 단순화된
양자 정보 공식화를 사용하면, 밀도 행렬 없이도 예를 들어
Shor의 인수분해 알고리즘 같은 양자 알고리즘을 어려움 없이 설명할 수 있어요. 그렇다면 왜 굳이 밀도 행렬을
또는 이 일반적인 양자 정보 공식화를 사용해야 할까요? 여러 이유가 있어요. 첫째로, 밀도 행렬은
양자 상태 벡터보다 더 넓은 범위의 양자 상태를 표현할 수 있어요. 불확실성이나
무작위성이 있는 양자 상태도 포함해요. 이건 양자 계산에서 노이즈의 영향을 모델링할 때 중요해요.
둘째로, 밀도 행렬을 사용하면 복합 시스템의 고립된 부분의 양자 상태를 설명할 수 있어요.
예를 들어, 다른 시스템과 얽혀 있어서 잠시 무시하고 싶은 시스템의 상태도요. 수업 시작 부분에서 언급했듯이,
이건 양자 정보의 단순화된 공식화에서는 쉽거나 자연스럽게 할 수 없는 거예요.
세 번째 이유는, 밀도 행렬을 사용하면 고전적인 정보가 실제로
특수한 경우로 나타난다는 거예요. 한쪽에는 확률적 상태와 연산 사이의 유사성이 있고
다른 한쪽에는 양자 상태 벡터와 유니터리 연산이 있는 것처럼 비유하는 게 아니라, 양자 및 고전적 정보가
단일한 수학적 프레임워크 안에서 함께 설명되는 거예요. 이건 양자 정보의 수학적 연구에 필수적이에요.
그래서 수학적인 수준에서 양자 정보를 진지하게 이해하고 싶다면, 밀도 행렬에 대해 배우는 것을 강력히
권장해요. 이제 밀도 행렬의 정의부터 시작해 볼게요.
정의를 위해, X가 시스템이고 시그마가 그 고전적 상태 집합이라고 가정해요. 그리고
그 용어를 사용할 때 우리의 가정은 시그마가 유한하고 비어 있지 않다는 거예요. 늘 그렇듯이 원하면
다른 이름을 선택할 수도 있어요. 시스템 X의 상태를 설명하는 밀도 행렬은 복소수
원소를 가진 행렬인데, 행과 열이 고전적 상태 집합과 대응되어 있어요. 명확히 말하면
행과 열이 동시에 같은 대응 관계를 가진다는 거예요. 이는 밀도
행렬이 항상 정방 행렬임을 의미해요. 정방 행렬이어야 하는 것 외에도 만족해야 할 몇 가지 조건이 있는데,
곧 다룰 거예요. 사람들은 보통 밀도 행렬을 나타내는 데 특정 소문자 그리스 문자를 사용해요.
로(ρ)가 흔히 첫 번째 선택이고, 다른 일반적인 선택으로는 소문자 시그마와 타우가 있어요. 화면에 나와 있어요.
이건 그냥 관례이지만, 이런 관례들은 보통 유용해요. 더 쉽게 인식할 수 있게 해주거든요.
이제 유효한 밀도 행렬이 되기 위해 충족해야 할 조건 또는 요구사항에 대해 이야기해 볼게요.
조건이 두 가지 있어요. 먼저 그것들을 나열하고
그 다음에 무엇을 의미하는지 더 자세히 설명할게요. 첫 번째 조건은
밀도 행렬이 단위 트레이스, 즉 트레이스가 1이어야 한다는 거예요. 두 번째 조건은
밀도 행렬이 양의 반정치여야 한다는 거예요. 두 경우 모두 화면에 나타난 것처럼 이 두 조건을 간결하게 기호로 표현할 수 있어요.
이제 두 조건을 더 자세히 살펴볼게요.
첫 번째 조건은 트레이스에 관한 것인데, 이건 모든 정방 행렬에 대해 정의된 아주 중요한 함수예요.
단순히 대각 원소들의 합이에요. 그걸 명시적으로 표현하는 방정식이 여기 있어요.
트레이스에 대해 할 말이 꽤 많고 중요한 이유도 있지만, 지금은 아주 기본적인
특성 하나만 살펴볼게요. 바로 선형 함수라는 점이에요. 트레이스의 다른 특성들은 나중에 필요할 때 다룰 거예요.
밀도 행렬에 집중하기 위해 두 번째 요구사항으로 넘어갈게요. 그 요구사항은
밀도 행렬이 양의 반정치여야 한다는 거예요. 이것도 여러 상황에서 나타나는 중요한 개념이에요.
물리학, 화학, 최적화, 머신러닝 등 여러 분야에서 나타나는 개념이에요. 그리고 서로 다르지만
동등한 방법으로 표현할 수 있어요. 행렬 ρ가 양의 반정치라는 걸 표현하는 한 가지 방법은, 어떤 행렬 M이 존재해서
ρ가 M†M과 같다고 말하는 거예요. 그리고 M 자체가 정방 행렬이어야 하는지 여부는 사실 중요하지 않아요.
그 제약을 없애도 마찬가지예요. 행렬 ρ가 양의 반정치라는 것을 표현하는 또 다른 방법은
ρ가 에르미트 행렬, 즉 켤레 전치와 같다고 말하는 거예요. 그리고 모든
고유값이 음이 아닌 실수여야 해요. 일반적으로 에르미트 행렬은
실수 고유값만 가질 수 있지만, 음수일 수도 있어요. 하지만 고유값이 음수가 될 수 없다는 조건을 추가하면
양의 반정치 행렬을 얻게 돼요. 그런데 어떤 행렬이 양의 반정치인지 알고 싶다면
이 특성으로 판단할 수 있어요. 행렬이 에르미트인지 확인하는 건 꽤 쉬워요.
그냥 눈으로 봐도 알 수 있어요. 고유값을 계산하는 건 더 어렵지만,
컴퓨터로 하면 어렵지 않아요. 매우 효율적인 알고리즘이 있거든요.
마지막으로 언급할 특성화는, 다른 것들도 있지만, ρ의 행과 열의 수와 같은 수의 원소를 가진 모든 열벡터 s에 대해
화면에 나타난 부등식이 성립한다는 거예요. 말로 표현하면, s†ρs는 음이 아닌 실수여야 해요.
이 특성화들이 모두 동등하다는 건 얼핏 보면 명확하지 않지만, 실제로 그렇거든요. 그리고 명시적으로 말씀드리면,
행렬 ρ가 양의 반정치임을 나타내는 데 흔히 사용하는 표기법은 ρ가 0보다 크거나 같다는 형태인데요.
이건 단순한 줄임 표기이고, ρ가 글자 그대로 0보다 크거나 같다는 뜻은 아니에요.
ρ는 행렬이니까 그게 말이 안 되겠죠. 그리고 ρ의 각 원소가 0보다 크거나 같다는 뜻도 아니에요.
특히, 원소가 모두 음이 아닌 것은 아닌 양의 반정치 행렬도 있고,
원소가 모두 음이 아니지만 양의 반정치가 아닌 행렬도 있어요.
이 표기법의 배경은, 양의 반정치 행렬이 음이 아닌 실수의 행렬 유사체 같다는 생각에서 나온 거예요.
하지만 이건 그냥 표기일 뿐이고, 그 의미는 정확히 이미 논의한 것이에요.
이제 몇 가지 예시를 살펴볼게요. 먼저 양의 반정치 행렬의 예시부터 시작할게요.
사실 양의 반정치 행렬의 예시를 무작위로 생성하는 건 꽤 쉬워요.
임의의 행렬 M을 선택한 다음 M†M을 계산하기만 하면 돼요.
예를 들어, 특별히 특별한 게 없는 행렬 M이 여기 있어요. 실제로
이 행렬은 원소의 실수 부분과 허수 부분을 -9와 9 사이의 정수로 독립적으로 선택해서 무작위로 생성한 거예요.
그래서 여기에 보이는 패턴이나 구조는 순전히 우연이에요. M의
켤레 전치를 M에 곱하면 바로 이 행렬을 얻게 되는데, 따라서 양의
반정치예요. 물론 무작위 예시에서 얻을 수 있는 통찰에는 한계가 있지만, 더 일반적으로
양의 반정치 행렬에서 공통적으로 나타나는 특징들을 보여줘요. 특히,
왼쪽 위에서 오른쪽 아래로 이어지는 선을 따라 있는 대각 원소들이 모두 음이 아닌 실수라는 걸 알 수 있어요.
그리고 대각이 아닌 원소들은 해당하는 대각 원소, 즉 같은 행과 같은 열에 있는 원소에 비해
그다지 크지 않아요. 어떤 비대각 원소를 보든 마찬가지예요.
하지만 이게 전부가 아니에요. 양의 반정치라는 건 행렬 전체의 특성이지
개별 원소에 대한 조건이 아니라는 걸 인식하는 게 중요해요. 이게 양의 반정치 행렬의 예시이고,
비슷한 방법으로 다른 예시들을 아주 쉽게 만들 수 있어요.
이제 양의 반정치 조건 외에 트레이스도 1인 밀도 행렬의 몇 가지 예시를 살펴볼게요.
여기 2×2 밀도 행렬의 몇 가지 예시가 있어요. 네 경우 모두 트레이스가 1이에요.
그리고 이것들이 에르미트 행렬임도 알 수 있어요. 따라서 이전의 두 번째 양의 반정치 특성화를 사용하면,
남은 것은 고유값이 모두 음이 아닌지 확인하는 거예요.
원하시면 직접 확인해 보셔도 좋아요. 2×2 행렬의 경우 손으로 고유값을 계산하는 게 그렇게 어렵지 않아요.
하지만 컴퓨터에 물어봐도 돼요. 예를 들어 Python의 선형 대수
패키지에서 eigvalsh 함수를 사용할 수 있어요. 그리고 0이 아닌 임의의
양의 반정치 행렬을 트레이스로 나눠서 밀도 행렬을 얻을 수도 있어요. 예를 들어, 조금 전에 본 예시를
트레이스로 나누면 이런 밀도 행렬을 얻어요. 이렇게 트레이스로 나누면
항상 양의 반정치 특성이 보존되고, 트레이스가 선형 함수라는 사실 덕분에
트레이스가 1인 행렬을 얻게 돼요. 이건 작은 예시 모음이고, 수업이 진행되면서 더 많은 것들을 보게 될 거예요.
다음으로 밀도 행렬의 해석이나 직관적인 의미에 대해
잠깐 이야기할게요. 먼저 인정해야 할 건,
시스템의 상태를 벡터가 아닌 행렬로 표현한다는 게 조금 낯설게 느껴질 수도 있다는 거예요.
이와 대조적으로, 양자 정보의 단순화된 공식화에서는 상태를 나타내는 데 벡터를 사용하고,
행렬, 특히 유니터리 행렬은 동작이나 연산을 나타내요. 이건 수학이 작동하는 방식이고,
행렬을 선형 매핑으로 설명하는 것으로 항상 생각할 수 있지만, 특정 밀도 행렬과 관련된
선형 매핑에 직접적인 직관적 의미를 부여하지는 않아요. 그렇긴 해도,
밀도 행렬이 실제로 행렬이라는 사실은 그것들의 중요한 측면으로 밝혀지며, 앞으로 계속
살펴볼 거예요. 지금 당장 한 가지 예시만 간단히 언급하면, 주어진 밀도 행렬의 고유값은
매우 중요한데, 왜냐하면 그 밀도 행렬이 설명하는 상태에 내재된 무작위성이나 불확실성의 정도를
나타내기 때문이에요. 직관적인 수준에서 밀도 행렬을 생각하는 또 다른 방법은
이 행렬들의 원소에 초점을 맞추는 거예요. 밀도 행렬의 행과 열이
우리가 이야기하는 시스템의 고전적 상태와 대응되어 있다는 걸 기억해 주세요. 따라서 각 원소에는 하나의
그 원소의 행에 해당하는 고전적 상태와 열에 해당하는 고전적 상태가 있어요.
대각 원소의 경우, 그 두 고전적 상태가 같은 상태예요. 그래서 대각 원소들이
특별한 거예요. 대각 원소들을 해석하는 한 가지 방법은, 그것들이 확률이라는 거예요. 구체적으로 말하면,
우리가 설명하는 양자 상태를 가진 시스템에서 표준 기저 측정을 수행했을 때
해당 고전적 상태가 나타날 확률이에요. 반면에 비대각 원소의 경우, 그 원소의 행에 해당하는 고전적 상태와
그 원소의 열에 해당하는 다른 고전적 상태가 있어요. 아주 비공식적으로 말하면,
이 원소들은 이 두 고전적 상태가 양자 중첩 상태에 있는 정도와 그들 사이의
상대적 위상을 설명해요. 수업이 계속 진행되고 특정 예시들을 더 자세히 살펴보면 더 이해가 될 거예요.
지금 당장 세부 사항이 명확하지 않더라도 걱정하지 마세요.
이건 꽤 비공식적인 내용이고, 그냥 머릿속에 담아둘 직관적인 아이디어예요.
다음으로 밀도 행렬과 양자 상태 벡터 사이의 연결을 살펴볼 거예요. 양자 상태 벡터는 유클리드 노름이 1인 열벡터예요.
수학적 정의를 다시 떠올려 볼게요. 어떤 특정 시스템의 상태를 나타내는
양자 상태 벡터 ψ가 있다고 가정하면, 같은 양자 상태를 나타내는 밀도 행렬은
화면에 나타난 것처럼 |ψ⟩⟨ψ|로 주어져요. 명확히 말하면, ψ의 인덱스는
우리가 이야기하는 시스템의 고전적 상태와 어떤 방식으로든 대응되어 있고, 그건 밀도 행렬의 행과 열과
시스템의 고전적 상태 사이의 대응과 정확히 같아요. 시스템의 고전적 상태가 n개 있다고 상상하고,
열벡터와 행벡터를 행렬로 생각하면, |ψ⟩는 n×1 행렬이고
⟨ψ|는 1×n 행렬이에요. 그래서 곱셈을 수행하면 n×n
행렬이 나와요. 사실 이건 그 형태 자체로 항상 양의 반정치 행렬이 되고, 또한 ψ가 단위 벡터이기 때문에
트레이스도 1이 돼요. 이건 곧 더 자세히 살펴볼 거예요.
이런 형태의 밀도 행렬로 표현되는 양자 상태를 순수
상태라고 해요. 몇 가지 예시를 살펴볼게요. 먼저 이 상태를 고려해 볼게요.
이건 플러스 상태와 비슷하지만, 고전적 상태 1에 해당하는 원소가
허수예요. 켤레 전치를 계산하면 마이너스 부호가 붙는데, i의 복소 켤레가
-i이기 때문이에요. 곱셈을 하면 화면에 나타난 행렬을 얻게 돼요. 에르미트 행렬임은
보기만 해도 바로 알 수 있어요. 그리고 고유값이 하나는 1이고 하나는 0이어서
양의 반정치이고, 트레이스도 1이에요. 따라서 예상대로 밀도 행렬이에요.
비슷한 방법으로 표준 기저와 플러스/마이너스 기저에 해당하는 밀도 행렬도 계산할 수 있는데,
그 밀도 행렬들이 여기 나타나 있어요. 그리고 시리즈의 첫 번째 수업에서 아주 오래전에 등장했던
양자 상태 벡터의 예시가 하나 더 있어요. 켤레 전치를 계산하고 곱셈을 하면
여기 나타난 밀도 행렬을 얻게 돼요. 다시 한 번 에르미트 행렬이고
트레이스가 1이에요. 고유값을 계산하면, 또 다시 하나는 1이고 하나는 0임을 알 수 있어요.
그런데 이게 모든 순수 상태의 공통 특성이에요. 항상 하나의 고유값이 1이고 나머지 고유값은 모두 0이에요.
일반적으로 임의의 원소 수를 가진 완전히 임의의 양자 상태 벡터 ψ에 대해, |ψ⟩에 ⟨ψ|를 곱하면
이런 모양의 밀도 행렬을 얻어요. 특히 대각 원소들이 항상 ψ의
원소와 그 복소 켤레를 곱한 것, 즉 그 원소의 절댓값 제곱임을 알 수 있어요.
이게 트레이스가 항상 1이 된다는 걸 보여주는 한 가지 방법이에요. 또한 수업 초반에 제가 밀도 행렬의 대각 원소들이
표준 기저 측정을 수행했을 때 각 고전적 상태가 나타날 확률을 알려준다고 했던 것과도 일치해요.
그리고 마지막으로 한 가지 더 언급하면,
밀도 행렬에서는 전역 위상 문제가 없어요. 두 양자 상태는 밀도 행렬이 같을 때, 그리고 오직 그때만 동일해요.
특히, 전역 위상까지만 같은 두 양자 상태 벡터 ψ와 φ가 있다고 가정해 볼게요.
이는 둘 중 하나, 예를 들어 φ를 단위원 위의 복소수를 다른 하나에 곱한 형태로 표현할 수 있다는 의미예요.
φ의 밀도 행렬 표현을 계산하면,
전역 위상 인수가 그 복소 켤레와 곱해져서 1이 된다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
따라서 그게 사실상 사라지고, ψ에서 얻는 것과 정확히 같은 밀도 행렬이 남아요.
이건 꽤 좋은 보너스고요. 더 일반적으로, 밀도 행렬을 사용할 때는
전역 위상 동치 문제가 전혀 없어요. 이건 양자 상태를 나타내는 데
밀도 행렬 대신 양자 상태 벡터를 사용할 때 존재하는 퇴화예요. 밀도 행렬은 핵심적인 특성을 가지고 있는데,
밀도 행렬의 볼록 조합이 양자 상태의 확률적 또는 무작위 선택을 나타낸다는 거예요.
달리 말하면, 밀도 행렬은 의미 있는 방식으로 평균을 낼 수 있는데,
이건 양자 상태 벡터에서는 할 수 없는 거예요. 이를 더 자세히 설명하기 위해, 어떤 시스템의 양자 상태를 나타내는
두 밀도 행렬 ρ와 σ가 있는 상황에서 시작해 볼게요. 0과 1 사이의 어떤 p에 대해
시스템이 확률 p로 상태 ρ에 준비되고, 그 외에는
상태 σ에 준비된다고 상상해 볼게요. 예를 들어 p가 1/2일 수도 있어요.
그러면 누군가가 공정한 동전을 던져서 앞면이 나오면 시스템을
상태 ρ로 남기는 어떤 과정을 수행하고, 뒷면이 나오면 시스템을
상태 σ로 남기는 다른 과정을 수행한다고 상상해 볼 수 있어요. 이제 질문은 시스템의 상태가 무엇인가인데,
명확히 말하면, 어떤 준비가 수행되었는지에 관한 다른 정보는 무시하고
시스템만 고립시켜서 그 상태에 관심이 있는 거예요. 예를 들어, 동전이나
상태 준비를 수행한 사람의 기억에 접근할 수 없다고 상상해 보세요. 그 질문의 답은, 단순히 두 밀도
행렬의 가중 평균, 즉 p×ρ + (1-p)×σ예요. 이건 사실
ρ와 σ가 밀도 행렬이 아니라 확률 상태를 나타내는 확률 벡터인 경우와 완전히 유사해요.
그러니까 이건 충격적이거나 신비한 게 아니라, 오히려 확률 이론에서
익숙한 것이에요. 우리는 확률을 계산하고 고전적인 무작위 선택을 생각할 때 항상 이런 종류의 평균을 사용해요.
그리고 요점은, 이게 밀도 행렬에도 작동한다는 거예요. 하지만 양자 상태 벡터에는 작동하지 않아요.
즉, 두 양자 상태 벡터를 이런 식으로 평균해서 유효한 양자 상태 벡터를 얻으려고 할 수는 없어요.
시도하면 보통 유클리드 노름이 1이 아닌 벡터를 얻게 돼요. 반면 밀도 행렬의 경우, 이런 가중 평균은 항상
유효한 밀도 행렬이 되고, 더 중요하게는 얻은 밀도 행렬이 그 무작위 선택을 의미 있는 방식으로 나타내요.
이건 두 가지 이상의 대안이 있는 무작위 선택으로 일반화돼요.
특히, m개의 가능한 밀도 행렬과 각 밀도 행렬에 하나씩 대응되는 m개의 원소를 가진 확률 벡터가 있고,
시스템이 각 가능한 상태에 해당하는 확률로 준비된다면,
그 밀도 행렬들의 가중 평균이 시스템의 결과 상태를 설명해요. 그런데 밀도 행렬의
볼록 조합이라고 할 때, 이게 그 의미예요. 볼록 조합은 단순히 계수가 확률 벡터를 이루는
선형 결합이에요. 이건 항상 밀도
행렬이 돼요. 수학적 용어로 간결하게 표현하면, 주어진 시스템에 해당하는 모든 밀도 행렬의 집합은
볼록 집합이에요. 예를 들어 m개의 양자 상태
벡터 ψ₀부터 ψₘ₋₁까지, 그리고 이들을 합하면 확률 벡터가 되는 확률 p₀부터 pₘ₋₁까지 있고,
시스템이 각 k에 대해 확률 pₖ로 상태 ψₖ에 준비된다면,
시스템의 결과 상태는 화면에 나타난 밀도 행렬로 설명돼요. 특히, 양자 상태
벡터 자체를 평균하는 게 아니라, 그에 해당하는 밀도 행렬들을 평균하는 거예요.
일반적으로 이런 상태는 단일 양자 상태 벡터로 표현되지 않아요.
모든 양자 상태 벡터가 전역 위상까지 동치이거나, 확률 중 하나를 제외한 나머지가 모두 0인 것처럼 무언가 사소한 일이 일어나지 않는 한요.
이런 과정에서 순수 양자 상태를 얻는 게 아니라, 어떤 내재적 불확실성이 포함된
혼합 양자 상태라고 하는 것을 얻어요. 간단한 예시를 살펴볼게요.
qubit이 있고 확률 1/2로 0 상태에 준비되고, 그렇지 않으면
플러스 상태에 준비된다고 가정해 볼게요. 제가 설명한 대로 평균을 내서 얻는 밀도 행렬이 여기 있어요.
두 가능한 상태에 해당하는 밀도 행렬을 계산하고, 해당 확률을 곱하고 더하면 돼요.
얻는 건 실제로 밀도 행렬이에요. 에르미트이고, 트레이스가 1이에요.
이 행렬의 고유값을 계산하면 두 양수 실수를 얻게 되는데, 지금쯤 익숙한 두 숫자일 거예요.
cos²(π/8)과 sin²(π/8), 즉 약 0.85와
0.15예요. 이 상태의 단일 양자 상태 벡터 표현은 없어요. 순수 상태가 아니에요. 다음으로 단일 qubit의 양자 상태를 나타내는 특정 밀도 행렬,
즉 완전히 혼합된 상태를 살펴볼게요.
이 상태는 자주 나타나기 때문에 이름을 갖는 게 좋고, 밀도 행렬의 중요한 특징을 보여주는 좋은 예시이기도 해요.
사실 모든 시스템에 대해 유사하게 정의된 완전히 혼합된 상태가 있지만,
지금은 단순하게 단일 qubit에 대한 이 상태에 집중할게요.
qubit의 상태를 각각 확률 1/2로 0 상태 또는 1 상태로 무작위로 설정한다고 가정해 볼게요.
균일한 무작위 비트와 비슷해요. 일반적인 방법으로 이 상태의 밀도 행렬 표현을 계산할 수 있어요.
두 상태의 밀도 행렬 표현의 평균을 취하면 돼요. 행렬 형태로 어떻게 되는지 보면,
얻는 건 2로 나눈 항등 행렬이에요.
이 상태를 완전히 혼합된 상태라고 하고, 기본적으로 qubit에 대한 완전한 또는 최대의
불확실성을 나타내요. 마치 균일한 확률 벡터가 고전적 확률 설정에서 최대 불확실성을 나타내는 것처럼요.
일반적으로 임의의 시스템에서 완전히 혼합된 상태는 표준 기저 상태를 균일하게 선택해서 얻는 상태이고,
밀도 행렬 표현은 차원, 즉 그 시스템의 고전적 상태의 수로 나눈
항등 행렬이 돼요. 지금 이건 단순한 용어이지만, 설정을 약간 바꾸면 밀도 행렬의 중요한 특징을 볼 수 있어요.
특히, 절차를 바꿔서 0과 1 표준 기저 상태 대신
플러스와 마이너스 상태로 대체한다고 가정해 볼게요. 이번에는 화면에 나타난
수식에서 시작하지만, 산술 과정을 거치면 정확히 같은
밀도 행렬을 얻게 돼요. 2로 나눈 항등 행렬이에요. 따라서 이전과 같은 상태,
즉 완전히 혼합된 상태예요. 이건 사람들이 말하듯이 버그가 아닌 기능이에요.
두 절차는 사실 다르지만, 결과로 얻은 qubit만 가지고 있다면 물리적으로 구별할 방법이 없어요.
통계적인 의미에서도 마찬가지예요. 예를 들어, 첫 번째 절차 수행 후 이 qubit에 표준 기저 측정을 수행하면
당연히 확률 1/2로 결과 0을, 확률 1/2로 결과 1을 얻게 돼요. 그런데 두 번째 절차에서도
정확히 같은 결과 확률을 얻게 돼요. 그리고 qubit 자체만 테스트한다고 가정하면,
다른 어떤 테스트를 고안하더라도 마찬가지예요. 일반적으로 밀도 행렬은 시스템이 어떻게 준비되었는지를 설명하지 않아요.
단지 그 시스템에 무언가를 할 경우 앞으로 무슨 일이 일어날지만 알려줘요. 연산을 수행하든
측정을 수행하든 마찬가지예요. 실제로 밀도 행렬은 이 점에서 완벽해요.
두 가지 다른 대안이 같은 밀도 행렬을 만들어낸다면, 통계적으로도
구별할 수 없어요. 하지만 두 밀도 행렬이 다르다면, 반드시 구별할 방법이 있어요.
결정적으로는 아닐 수도 있지만, 통계적인 의미에서는요. 양자 정보의 일반적인 공식화를 사용할 때
반드시 결정적으로는 아니지만 통계적인 의미에서 quantum 정보의 일반적인 공식화를 사용할 때
고전적 정보가 특수한 경우로 본질적으로 나타나요. 이제 그게 어떻게 작동하는지 설명할게요.
구체적으로, 확률 상태가 밀도 행렬로 어떻게 표현될 수 있는지 살펴볼 거예요.
고전적 상태부터 시작해 볼게요. 간단한
예시부터 시작할게요. qubit의 0과 1 표준 기저 상태의 밀도 행렬 표현이 여기 있어요.
이 상태들을 고전적 상태 0과 1에 연관시키면, 이 밀도 행렬들이 그 상태들을 나타낸다고 생각할 수 있어요.
아주 간단하고, 쉽게 일반화할 수 있어요.
고전적 상태 집합이 시그마인 시스템이 있다면, 고전적 상태 a는 밀도 행렬 |a⟩⟨a|로 표현되거나
연관돼요. 그 행렬은 고전적 상태 a에 해당하는 행과 열의 대각 원소에 1이 하나 있고,
다른 모든 원소는 0이에요. 확률 상태는 이런 형태의 행렬들의 볼록 조합으로 표현되는데,
이건 밀도 행렬과 작동 방식에 대해 알고 있는 것, 즉 밀도 행렬의 볼록 조합이 무작위 또는
확률적 양자 상태 선택을 나타낸다는 사실을 고려하면 자연스러운 거예요. 예를 들어, 고전적 상태 집합이 어떤 양의 정수 n에 대해 0부터 n-1까지의 정수를 포함하는
시스템 X가 있다고 가정해 볼게요.
물론 고전적 상태 집합이 이 형태라고 가정해도 일반성을 거의 잃지 않아요. 다른 고전적 상태 집합이 있다면
단순히 고전적 상태의 이름을 이렇게 바꾸면 돼요. 그리고 고전적 상태 집합이 이런 형태라고 가정하면 꽤 편리해요.
주로 벡터와 행렬 측면에서 명시적으로 쓰기가 더 쉬워지거든요.
시스템 X의 확률 상태가 일반적인 방식으로 확률 벡터로 표현된다고 가정하면,
이 확률 상태를 밀도 행렬과 연관시킬 수 있어요.
화면에 나타난 것처럼요. 서로 다른 고전적 상태에 해당하는 밀도 행렬들의 가중 평균을 취하면,
대각 밀도 행렬을 얻게 돼요. 특히 이 행렬의 대각선에 확률들이 나타나고,
다른 모든 원소는 0이에요. 물론 이건 밀도 행렬이에요.
그게 사실이어야 한다고 예상하지만, 직접적으로도 추론할 수 있어요. 에르미트 행렬이고, 확률이 합산되어 1이 되기 때문에 트레이스가 1이에요.
대각 행렬의 경우 고유값이 대각 원소이고,
이들은 확률이기 때문에 모두 음이 아니에요. 또한 모든 비대각 원소가 0인 모든 대각 밀도 행렬은
이런 형태여야 함을 알 수 있어요. 간단히 말하면,
확률 상태는 대각 밀도 행렬과 연관될 수 있어요. 이건 수업 초반에 제가 언급한 밀도 행렬 원소들의
비공식적 해석과 일치한다는 점도 알아두세요. 특히 양자 중첩이 없어요.
기본적으로 고전적인 무작위성일 뿐이고, 그에 따라 모든 비대각 원소가 0이에요.
이 시리즈 앞부분에서 스펙트럼 정리에 대해 이야기했는데, 위상 추정의 맥락에서
유니터리 행렬에 대해 구체적으로 다뤘어요. 스펙트럼 정리는 그것보다 더 일반적이에요.
즉, 유니터리 행렬보다 더 넓은 범위의 행렬에 대해 무언가를 알려줘요.
특히, 모든 에르미트 행렬과 유니터리 행렬을 포함하는 정규 행렬이라는 행렬 클래스에 적용돼요.
이제 이 정리를 다르게 진술해 볼 거예요. 이번에는 양의 반정치 행렬에만 집중해서,
밀도 행렬에 대해 아주 흥미롭고 매우 중요한 것을 알려준다는 걸 보게 될 거예요.
P가 임의의 양의 반정치 행렬이라고 가정해 볼게요. 이건 트레이스가 1인 밀도 행렬을 포함해요.
P는 양의 반정치이므로 n×n의 정방 행렬이어야 해요. 그 n을 참조해야 하니까 n을
적절하게 선택하거나, 다시 말해 P가 n×n이라고 가정해요. 이 경우 정리가 알려주는 건,
ψ₀부터 ψₙ₋₁까지 이름 붙인 정규 직교 기저 벡터가 존재해야 하고, 음이 아닌 실수
λ₀부터 λₙ₋₁까지도 존재해서 P를 화면에 나타난 것처럼 표현할 수 있다는 거예요.
말로 표현하면, 각 λₖ에 |ψₖ⟩⟨ψₖ|를 곱하고 k를 0부터 n-1까지 합산하면 P를 얻어요.
이것을 P의 스펙트럼 분해라고 해요. 각 λₖ는 반드시 P의 고유값이고,
각 ψₖ는 그 고유값에 해당하는 P의 단위 고유 벡터예요.
위상 추정에 관한 7번 수업을 다시 보면, 유니터리 행렬에 대한 유사한 정리를 찾을 수 있어요.
거기서 고유값은 음이 아닌 실수가 아니라 단위원 위의 복소수예요. 하지만 나머지는 같은 아이디어예요.
이것들은 사실 스펙트럼 정리라고 하는 더 일반적인 정리의 두 가지 특수한 경우예요.
모든 행렬에 대해 작동하지는 않아요. 행렬이 켤레 전치와 교환 가능해야 해요.
그게 행렬이 정규 행렬이라는 의미예요. 하지만 실제로 유니터리 행렬과 양의 반정치 행렬 모두에 대해
항상 성립해요. 더 일반적으로 에르미트 행렬에서는 실수 고유값은 항상 있지만 반드시 음이 아닌 건 아니에요.
그래서 양의 반정치 행렬에 대한 스펙트럼 정리를 진술했고,
이제 그게 밀도 행렬에 대해 무엇을 알려주는지 살펴볼게요.
이게 알려주는 건, 임의의 n×n 밀도 행렬에 대해 항상 그 행렬을 n개의 순수 상태의 볼록
조합으로 표현할 수 있다는 거예요. 더욱이 그 n개의 순수 상태를
직교하게 선택할 수 있어요. 이건 정리와 선형 대수의 기본 사실, 즉 임의의 행렬의 고유값의 합이 항상 그 행렬의 트레이스와 같다는 것으로부터 꽤 직접적으로 따라나와요.
다시 말해, 우리가 실제로 하는 건 고유값의 이름을 p₀부터 pₙ₋₁까지 바꾸고,
그 고유값들을 n차원 벡터로 모으면 반드시 확률 벡터가 된다는 걸 관찰하는 거예요.
모두 음이 아니어야 하고, 합이 ρ의 트레이스와 같아야 하는데, ρ가 밀도 행렬이니까 그게 1이에요.
이건 꽤 간단하지만, 개념적으로는 정말 근본적이에요. 이게 알려주는 건, 아무리 복잡해 보여도 모든 밀도 행렬은
우리가 이야기하는 시스템의 정규 직교 기저를 먼저 선택하고,
그 다음 어떤 확률에 따라 그 기저에서 무작위로 양자 상태를 선택해서 얻을 수 있다는 거예요.
아무리 복잡해 보이더라도, 먼저 어떤 시스템의 정규 직교 기저를 선택하는 것에서 나올 수 있어요.
그리고 어떤 확률 분포에 따라 그 기저에서 무작위로 quantum state를 선택하는 것이에요.
왜 그게 흥미롭거나 중요한지 표면적으로 바로 명확하지 않더라도 괜찮아요. 실제로 밀도 행렬에 대해 추론할 때 이 사실을 매우 자주 사용하고,
주어진 밀도 행렬을 이런 방식으로 표현하는 것이 그것을 더 잘
이해하고 싶을 때 종종 맨 처음 하는 것이에요. 예시를 보여줄게요. 이전에 나왔던 밀도 행렬을 떠올려 보세요. 각각 확률 1/2로
0 상태와 플러스 상태 사이에서 무작위로 선택하는 경우인데, 계산한 것처럼 밀도 행렬이
이런 형태예요. 0 상태와 플러스 상태는 직교하지 않아서 이건
스펙트럼 분해가 아니에요. 하지만 이런 경우 컴퓨터나 손으로 스펙트럼 분해를 계산하면,
밀도 행렬을 이렇게 표현할 수 있어요. 고유값은 계속 나오는 이 숫자들이고,
해당하는 고유 벡터는 화면 아래에 나타난 것처럼 선택할 수 있어요. 이 벡터들은 이전에 본 적 있어요. 예를 들어
4번 수업의 CHSH 게임 맥락에서요. 흥미롭죠. 원래 표현에 따르면 이 상태는 0 상태와
플러스 상태 두 가지 중에서 균일하게 선택해서 얻는 거예요. 하지만 실제로 두 순수 상태 중에서 무작위로 선택해도
정확히 같은 밀도 행렬을 얻어요. 단, 하나 쪽으로 아주 강하게 편향되어 있어요. 첫 번째 쪽으로 약 85%, 두 번째 쪽으로는 약 15%만요.
그래서 어떤 의미에서는 상태에 내재된 무작위성이 원래 보였던 것보다
실제로 훨씬 적어요. 단일 qubit의 양자 상태를 생각하고 시각화하는 아주 멋진 기하학적 방법이 있는데,
Bloch 구라고 해요. 이건 단일 qubit에만 작동해요. 두 개 이상의 고전적 상태를 가진 시스템,
즉 두 개 이상의 qubit이 함께 있는 경우에는 더 이상 작동하지 않아요. 꽤 제한적이지만,
그래도 단일 qubit의 상태를 생각하는 아주 좋은 방법이에요. 시리즈의 첫 번째 수업에서
이미 소개될 수도 있었지만, 양자 정보가 어떻게 작동하는지 이해하는 데 꼭 필수적인 건 아니고, 밀도 행렬과 아주 멋진
연결 관계가 있기 때문에 이 수업에 자연스럽게 맞아떨어져요. 실제로 밀도 행렬을 사용해서
효과적으로 유도하는 방식으로 조금 다르게 설명할 거예요. 이미 Bloch 구에 익숙하다면 이 설명이
처음 배운 방식과 조금 다를 수 있지만, 결국에는 물론 동등할 거예요. 먼저 qubit의 가능한 순수 상태에 대해
양자 상태 벡터로 표현된 것을 생각해 볼게요.
전역 위상까지 모든 qubit 양자 상태 벡터는 화면에 나타난 것처럼 표현할 수 있어요.
정확히 말하면, 두 실수 θ와 φ가 있는데, 이 두 숫자를 라디안으로 표현된 각도로 생각할 거예요.
첫 번째 숫자 θ는 0과 π 사이에 있어요. 동치로 말하면, 0도와 180도 사이의 각도예요.
두 번째 숫자 φ는 0과 2π 사이에 있는데, 0은 포함하고 2π는
포함하지 않아요. 그래서 0도와 360도 사이의 어떤 각도든 돼요. 벡터의 0번째 원소는
θ/2의 코사인이에요. 그래서 0과 1 사이의 실수이고, 특히 반드시 음이 아니에요.
그리고 벡터의 1번째 원소는 e^(iφ) × sin(θ/2)이고, 그건 복소 단위원 위나 안에 있는 어떤 복소수든 될 수 있어요.
이건 항상 단위 벡터이고, 즉 유효한 양자 상태 벡터예요. 주어진 qubit 양자 상태 벡터에 대해
항상 전역 위상까지 그 벡터와 동치인 이 형태의 벡터를 찾을 수 있어요.
특히, 주어진 벡터에 전역 위상을 곱해서 0번째 원소를 음이 아닌 실수로 만들 수 있어요. 그 원소를 주는
θ를 선택하고, 그 다음 1번째 원소와 일치하는 φ를 선택하면 돼요. 1번째 원소의 크기는
단위 벡터로 시작했다는 가정에 의해 항상 θ/2의 사인과 일치해요.
이제 θ와 φ가 시작한 양자 상태 벡터에 의해 유일하게 결정되지는 않아요.
하지만 거의 그래요. 작동하는 0과 π 사이의 유일한 θ 값은 항상 있어요.
그리고 보통 작동하는 유일한 φ 값이 있지만, 두 가지 특수한 경우에는 그렇지 않아요.
특히, 표준 기저 상태에서 시작하면 θ가 0 또는 π가 되는데, 두 경우 모두 φ가 실제로 무엇인지 중요하지 않아요.
완전히 무관해요. θ가 0이면 θ/2의 코사인은 1이고 θ/2의 사인은
0이에요. 그래서 e^(iφ)에 0을 곱하니까 φ가 무엇이든 차이가 없어요.
θ가 π이면 이번에는 코사인이 0이고 사인이 1이에요. 따라서 e^(iφ) × |1⟩인데, 이 벡터들은 모두 전역 위상까지 동치예요.
그러므로 다시 한 번 φ가 무엇인지 중요하지 않아요. 하지만 θ가 0과 π 사이에 진정으로 있다면,
항상 작동하는 유일한 φ 값이 있어요. 그런데 두 특수한 경우에 φ 값의 가능한 이 퇴화는
잠시 후 기하학적 그림을 보면 완벽하게 이해가 될 거예요.
이제 방금 확인한 형태의 상태 벡터와 관련된 밀도 행렬을 계산해 볼게요.
이건 qubit의 순수 상태예요. 이를 위해 평소대로 벡터를 켤레 전치와 곱해요.
화면에는 켤레 전치를 계산하고 곱셈을 수행해서 얻는 행렬의 식이 있어요.
모든 2×2 행렬처럼, Pauli 행렬의 선형 결합으로 이 행렬을 얻는 유일한 방법이 있어요.
항등 행렬을 포함해서요. 특히 화면에 나타난 것처럼 Pauli 행렬의 계수를 선택해서 이 행렬을 얻을 수 있어요.
분모에 2를 넣는 건 모든 게 멋지게 정리되기 때문이에요. 이렇게 해야 하는 건 아니지만, 할 수 있고 도움이 돼요.
하지만 이 외관상의 선택을 제외하면 다른 선택의 여지가 없어요. 이게 Pauli 행렬의 선형 결합으로 이 행렬을 얻는 유일한 방법이에요.
항등 행렬을 포함한 Pauli 행렬들이 모든 2×2 행렬의 벡터 공간에 대한 기저이기 때문이에요.
이 식의 정확성을 확인하는 한 가지 방법은 기본적인 삼각 함수 항등식을 사용하는 거예요. 특히 제가 잠깐 비켜서면
여기 도움이 될 몇 가지 항등식이 있어요. 원하시면 영상을 일시 정지하거나
스크린샷을 찍고, 첫 번째 밀도 행렬 식에서 아래쪽 두 번째 식을 유도할 수 있는지 확인해 보세요.
요약하면, 밀도 행렬로 표현된 qubit의 순수 상태는 화면에 나타난 것처럼 Pauli 행렬의 선형 결합으로 쓸 수 있어요.
왜냐하면 identity matrix를 포함한 Pauli 행렬들이 모든 2x2 행렬의 벡터 공간에 대한 기저이기 때문이에요. 한 가지
이 표현의 정확성을 확인하는 방법은 몇 가지 기본적인 삼각 항등식을 이용하는 거예요. 특히 잠깐 비켜서
보면 여기에 필요한 항등식들이 있어요. 원하신다면 영상을 잠깐 멈추거나
스크린샷을 찍고, 첫 번째 표현에서 아래의 density matrix의 두 번째 표현을 얻을 수 있는지 확인해 보세요. 요약하면, qubit의 순수 상태는
density matrix로 표현했을 때 화면에 나타난 것처럼 Pauli 행렬의 선형 결합으로 쓸 수 있어요.
θ가 0과 π 사이이고 φ가 0과 2π 사이일 때, 이전과 정확히 같은
퇴화가 있다는 걸 알 수 있어요. θ가 0 또는 π일 때 φ가 무관한 것이요. 이번에는 그걸 더 명확하게 볼 수 있어요.
왜냐하면 그 두 경우에 sin(θ)가 0이고, 그 외에는 그렇지 않기 때문이에요. 이 공식에서
θ/2 대신 θ가 사인과 코사인 함수의 인수로 나타난다는 점을 지적할 만해요. 원래 양자 상태 벡터 버전과 달리 그런 건데,
삼각 함수 항등식을 사용했기 때문이에요. 처음 세 가지는 기본적으로 소위 배각 공식의 재배열이에요.
그래서 각도가 효과적으로 두 배가 돼요. 이제 드디어 Bloch 구 자체에 대해 이야기할 준비가 됐어요.
밀도 행렬의 식에서 항등이 아닌 Pauli 행렬의 분자에 있는 세 계수에 집중해 볼게요.
그래서 분모의 2는 무시하고,
항등 행렬도 무시해요. 그 위의 계수는 절대 바뀌지 않기 때문이에요. 그건 우리가 표현하는 어떤 행렬의 트레이스에 의해 결정되고, 밀도 행렬은 항상 트레이스가 1이에요.
이제 x, y, z로 레이블된 세 축이 소위 오른손 법칙에 따라 방향이 정해져 있다고 상상하고,
세 계수와 일치하는 좌표를 가진 점을 고려해 볼게요. 명확히 말하면, 이건 좌표가 항상 실수인
일반적인 3차원 공간이에요. x 좌표는 식 분자에서 σ_X Pauli 행렬의 계수에 해당해요.
이건 항상 실수예요. 밀도 행렬이 에르미트이기 때문이에요. y와 z에 대해서도 마찬가지예요.
이 점이 항상 단위 구 위에 있다는 걸 알 수 있어요. 즉, 반지름이 1인 구예요.
특히, 양의 z축이 구와 교차하는 점에서 시작해서
그게 북극이라고 생각할 수 있는 곳이에요. θ만큼 양의 x축 쪽으로 아래로 회전하고,
그 다음 양의 y축 쪽으로, 즉 동쪽으로 φ만큼 회전해서 얻는 점이에요. 이 맥락에서 θ를
극각이라고 해요. 극점에서 시작하기 때문에 기억하기 쉬워요. φ는 방위각이라고 해요.
이 두 각도는 함께 단위 구 위의 점에 대한 구면 좌표를 나타내요. 반지름을 변화시키면
3차원 공간의 임의의 점을 나타낼 수도 있지만, 여기서는 반지름이 1인 단위 구 위의 점에 집중해요.
θ를 위도라고 생각할 수도 있는데, 다만 적도에서 ±90도가 아니라 북극에서 남극까지 0도에서 180도로 가는 거예요.
그리고 φ는 경도를 나타내는데, 기본적으로 양의 x축과 교차하는 자오선을 본초자오선으로 정의해요.
그런데 저처럼 위도와 경도 중 어느 게 어느 건지 헷갈린다면, 경도는 더 긴 구간, 즉 π가 아닌 2π에 해당한다고 기억하면 도움이 돼요.
어쨌든, qubit 상태 벡터 ψ에서 이런 방식으로 좌표를 생각해서 단위 구 위에서 얻는 점은
ψ에 해당하는 양자 상태의 Bloch 구 표현이에요. 그리고 전체 3차원 단위 구를 이런 방식으로 생각하면 Bloch 구를 얻어요.
기하학적으로는 그냥 일반적인 3차원 공간의 단위 구이지만, 실제로 그게 qubit
상태의 기하학이에요. 여기에는 완벽한 일대일 대응이 있어요. qubit의 모든 순수 상태는 구 위의 고유한 점에 해당하고,
구 위의 모든 점은 전역 위상까지 고유한 qubit 상태를 나타내요. 양자 상태 벡터를 다룰 때
이 대응은 다른 이름으로도 불려요. 예를 들어 Poincaré 구라고도 해요.
하지만 양자 정보의 맥락에서는 일반적으로 Bloch 구라고 불러요. 이제 각도 φ의 퇴화를 꽤 명확하게 볼 수 있어요.
왜냐하면 북극과 남극에서는 경도가 의미가 없기 때문이에요. 하지만 극점을 제외하면 지구 위의 모든 점은 위도와 경도 측면에서 고유한 좌표를 가지고, 여기서도 같은 일이 일어나요.
그래서 일반적으로 Bloch 구가 어떻게 작동하는지 설명했어요. 이제 qubit 상태의 몇 가지 특정 예시와
Bloch 구 위에서 어디에 있는지 살펴볼게요.
표준 기저부터 시작할게요. 0 상태에서는 극각 θ가 0이고, 1 상태에서는 π일 때 얻는 점이에요.
이미 이야기한 것처럼 방위각 φ가 무관한 두 경우예요. 해당하는 밀도 행렬도 Pauli 행렬의 선형
결합으로 표현할 수 있어요. 두 방법 모두 이 두 상태가 Bloch 구의 북극과 남극에 해당한다는 결론을 내려요.
0 상태는 위에, 1 상태는 아래에 있어요.
다음으로 Bloch 구 위에서 플러스와 마이너스 상태를 찾아볼게요. 다시 양자 상태 벡터나 밀도 행렬을 생각해 볼 수 있어요.
양자 상태 벡터에 대해서는 이번에 극각 θ가 π/2여야 해요. 0번째 원소가 1/√2가 되려면요.
방위각 φ는 플러스 상태의 경우 0이어야 해요. 플러스 상태에서 1번째 원소가 양수이기 때문이에요.
마이너스 상태의 경우에는 π 또는 180도여야 해요. 그 경우 1번째 원소가 음수이기 때문이에요.
따라서 이 두 점은 Bloch 구의 적도 위에 있어요. 플러스 상태는 양의 x축이 구와 교차하는 곳이고,
마이너스 상태는 반대편으로 음의 x축이 구와 교차하는 곳이에요. 해당하는 밀도 행렬의 Pauli 행렬 표현을 봐도
y와 z 좌표가 모두 0이고, x 좌표가 양수 1과 음수 1임을 알 수 있어요.
또 다른 예시는 플러스 i, 마이너스 i 기저인데, 플러스/마이너스 기저와 비슷하지만 1번째 원소에 허수 단위 i를 추가로 곱해요.
플러스 i 상태는 수업 초반에 봤고, 마이너스 i 상태는 유사한 방식으로 정의돼요.
극각 θ는 플러스/마이너스 상태와 같이 π/2이고, 이번에는 i와 -i를 얻으려면 방위각 φ를 선택해야 해요.
1과 -1 대신요. π/2와 3π/2가 그걸 만들어내는 올바른 선택이에요.
다시 한 번 이 상태들의 밀도 행렬 설명을 봐도 이전 두 예시와 꽤 유사해요. 다만 이번에는 σ_Z나 σ_X 대신 Pauli y 행렬이 있어요.
따라서 Bloch 구에서 이 두 상태는 y축이 구와 교차하는 곳에 있어요.
정리해 보면, 방금 이야기한 여섯 가지 상태가 서로 어떻게 관련되는지 더 명확하게 볼 수 있어요.
또 다른 예시, 사실은 예시의 클래스로, 이전과 4번 수업에서 나온 qubit 상태 벡터를 고려해 볼게요.
0번째 원소가 어떤 실수 α에 대해 cos(α)이고,
2이고, 이번에는 1과 -1 대신 I와 -I를 얻을 수 있도록 방위각 φ를 선택해야 해요.
그리고 π/2와 3π/2가 그렇게 하기 위한 올바른 선택이에요. 다시 한 번, 이 상태들의
density matrix 설명을 살펴볼 수도 있는데, 이번에는 Z나 X 대신 Pauli Y 행렬이 있다는 점을 제외하면 앞의 두 예시와 꽤 비슷해요.
그래서 Bloch sphere에서 이 두 상태는 y축이
구와 교차하는 곳에 위치해요. 조금 정리해 보면, 방금 논의한 여섯 가지 상태들이
어떻게 서로 관련되는지 더 명확하게 볼 수 있어요. 마지막으로 하나 더, 실제로는 예시들의 집합인데,
앞서 그리고 4번 수업에서 나왔던 qubit state vector를 생각해 보세요. 여기서 0번째 원소는 어떤 실수 α에 대해 cos(α)이고,
1번째 원소는 sin(α)예요. 그런데 α의 범위를 0과 π 사이로 제한할 수 있어요. 다른 α 값은
α가 이 범위에 있는 벡터와 전역 위상까지 동치인 벡터를 주기 때문이에요.
이 상태들과 관련된 밀도 행렬을 Pauli 행렬의 선형 결합으로 표현해서 계산하면,
화면에 나타난 식을 얻어요. 그 계산은 여기 나와 있지 않지만, 직접 해보면 그게 나올 거예요.
그리고 이 상태들이 극을 지나는 소위 대원을 형성한다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
구체적으로 α가 0일 때 북극에서 시작해서 본초자오선을 따라 내려가다가
α가 π/2일 때 남극에 닿고, 그 다음 α가 π/2에서 π로 증가하면서 구의 반대편을 통해 북극으로 돌아와요.
이건 다 말이 되는데, 첫째로 이것들이 실수 벡터이기 때문에 허수 부분이 항상 0이고, 둘째로
각도 α가 Bloch 구에서 효과적으로 두 배가 되기 때문이에요. 이것도 배각 공식의 사용으로 설명할 수 있어요.
Bloch 구가 qubit의 순수 상태에 대한 아주 멋진 기하학적 표현을 제공한다는 걸 봤어요.
구 위의 각 점은 qubit의 고유한 순수 상태에 해당하고, 반대로도 마찬가지예요.
Bloch 공이라고 할 때는 Bloch 구 위의 모든 점과 그 안에 포함된 점들도 이야기하는 거예요.
Bloch 공 내부의 점들도 qubit 상태에 해당해요.
구체적으로는 순수 상태가 아닌 상태예요. 즉, 밀도 행렬로는 표현할 수 있지만 qubit 상태 벡터로는 표현할 수 없는 qubit 상태예요.
Bloch 공의 근본적인 측면과 내부 점이 비순수 상태를 나타내는 방식은,
Bloch 공 내부 점들의 볼록 조합이 밀도 행렬들의 볼록 조합에 해당한다는 거예요.
직관적으로 말하면, 기하학이 Bloch 공 내부에서도 완벽하게 작동한다는 의미예요.
몇 가지 예시를 살펴볼게요. 완전히 혼합된 상태를 나타내는 Bloch 공의 중심점부터 시작할게요.
완전히 혼합된 상태는 0과 1 상태를 평균해서 얻어요. 이건 구의 중심이 북극과 남극의 정확히 중간에 있다는 사실과 일치해요.
실제로 플러스와 마이너스 상태나 플러스 i와 마이너스 i 상태 같은 두 대척점의 정확히 중간이에요.
Bloch 구에서 대척점들은 항상 직교하는 순수 상태에 해당해요. 이게 드러내거나 반영하는 건,
완전히 혼합된 상태를 항상 임의의 두 직교하는 순수 qubit 상태의 평균으로 쓸 수 있다는 거예요.
이를 보는 또 다른 방법은 완전히 혼합된 상태의 Pauli 행렬 표현을 생각하는 거예요.
이걸 만족시키려면 항등이 아닌 세 Pauli 행렬의 계수를 모두 0으로 설정해야 해요.
따라서 Bloch 공 안의 해당 점은 원점 한가운데에 있어요. 그런데 밀도 행렬의 Pauli 행렬 표현을 이렇게 생각하면
Bloch 공 점들의 볼록 조합이 밀도 행렬들의 볼록 조합에 해당한다는 게 꽤 명확해져요.
밀도 행렬의 평균이나 가중 평균을 취하고 모든 것을 Pauli 행렬의 선형 결합으로 표현하면,
물론 해당하는 점들을 평균하는 것과 같아요. 세 계수에서 모든 게 선형이기 때문이에요.
마지막 예시로, 수업 초반에 본 0 상태와 플러스 상태의 평균을 고려해 볼게요.
밀도 행렬 표현을 계산했는데 화면에 나타나 있어요. 그리고 그 점은 0과 플러스 상태의 중간 위치인 Bloch 공 내부에 있어요.
또 이 밀도 행렬을 스펙트럼 분해에 기반한 다른 방식으로 표현할 수 있다는 것도 봤는데,
그것도 다이어그램과 이전 예시들과 일치해요. 그리고 이걸로 Bloch 구와 Bloch 공에 대한 이야기를 마무리할게요.
사람들은 종종 세 개 이상의 고전적 상태를 가진 시스템에 대한 Bloch 구나 Bloch 공이 있는지 물어봐요.
안타깝게도 답은 사실상 없어요. 시스템의 양자 상태를 기하학적 측면에서 항상 생각할 수 있고,
Bloch 공과 유사하게요. 실수 벡터 공간에서 볼록 물체를 얻기는 해요.
하지만 세 개 이상의 고전적 상태가 있으면 구형이 되지 않아요. 예를 들어, 정확히 세 개의 고전적 상태,
즉 큐트릿이 있다면 8차원 공간의 볼록 물체를 얻어요. 하지만 그 물체의 극점들, 즉 큐트릿의 순수 양자 상태에 해당하는 것들은
4차원 다양체를 이루어요. 8차원 공간에서 4차원 다양체를 가져다가
수축 포장해서 볼록 물체를 만드는 걸 시각화할 수 있고, 그게 큐트릿에 대해 생각하는 유용한 방법이라고 생각한다면, 자유예요.
생각해볼 만한 흥미로운 내용이지만, 공이 아니에요. 그보다 더 복잡해요. 수업의 마지막 부분에서는 밀도 행렬이
다중 시스템에서 어떻게 작동하는지 간단히 이야기할 거예요. 밀도 행렬은 다중 시스템의 상태를 나타낼 수 있고,
이건 양자 상태 벡터와 완전히 유사한 방식으로 작동해요. 특히 양자 정보의 단순화된 공식화에서와 마찬가지로,
다중 시스템을 마치 단일 복합 시스템인 것처럼 볼 수 있어요.
이번에는 다중 시스템의 상태를 나타내는 밀도 행렬의 행과 열 모두
개별 시스템들의 고전적 상태 집합의 데카르트 곱과 대응되어 있어요.
예를 들어, 네 가지 벨 상태의 밀도 행렬 표현을 고려할 수 있어요.
이건 수업 초반에 다른 양자 상태 벡터들에 대해 했던 것처럼, 상태 벡터를 켤레 전치와 곱해서 정확히 같은 방식으로 얻어요.
결과는 화면에 나타나 있어요. 본질적으로 개념적 수준에서는 정말 새로운 게 없어요. 하지만 곧 밀도 행렬로 다중 시스템에서
할 수 있는 새로운 것들이 있다는 걸 보게 될 거예요.
독립성과 상관관계의 개념은 양자 상태 벡터에서 밀도 행렬로 이어져요. 특히 밀도 행렬의 텐서 곱이 시스템 간의 독립성을 나타낸다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
양자 상태 벡터에서 사용했던 것과 같은 용어를 사용해요. 예를 들어, 상태 ρ에 준비된 시스템 X와
독립적으로 상태 σ에 준비된 시스템 Y가 있다면, 쌍 XY의 상태는 ρ와 σ의 텐서 곱으로 주어져요.
이걸 곱 상태라고 해요. 이건 두 개 이상의 시스템으로 자연스럽게 일반화돼요.
곱 상태로 표현할 수 없는 밀도 행렬은 시스템 간의 상관관계를 나타내요. 이 부분은 양자 상태 벡터와 비슷해요.
하지만 밀도 행렬을 사용할 때는 심지어 두 시스템만 있어도 다양한 유형의 상관관계가 나타날 수 있어요.
이와 대조적으로, 양자 상태 벡터에서는 실제로 한 가지 유형의 상관관계만 가질 수 있어요.
그게 바로 얽힘이에요. 달리 말하면, 양자 상태 벡터에서는 상관관계와 얽힘이 동의어지만,
그 부분은 quantum state vector와 비슷하지만, 알고 보면 density matrix를 사용할 때 생길 수 있는 상관관계의 유형이 달라요. 심지어
두 시스템만 있어도요. 반면에 quantum state vector에서는 가질 수 있는 상관관계가 정말 한 종류뿐인데,
바로 entanglement예요. 다르게 말하면, quantum state vector에서는 상관관계와 entanglement가 동의어지만,
밀도 행렬에서는 그렇지 않아요. 여기서는 더 흥미로운 것들이 있어요. 예를 들어, 밀도 행렬로 상관된 고전적 상태를 설명할 수 있어요.
여기 Alice와 Bob이 공유하는 고전적 무작위 비트를 나타내는 밀도 행렬의 예시가 있어요.
이들은 항상 같은 고전적 상태, 0 또는 1을 가지고, 각 경우의 확률은
1/2이에요. 이건 얽힌 상태가 아니에요. 얽힘은 비고전적이에요. 하지만
상관된 상태이긴 해요. 또 다른 예시는 양자 상태의 앙상블 개념과 연결돼요.
이건 유한한 양자 상태 집합 위의 확률 분포라고 생각할 수 있어요. 특히, m개의 밀도 행렬 ρ₀부터 ρₘ₋₁까지가 있고,
모두 특정 시스템의 가능한 상태를 나타내며, 각각을 선택할 확률이 있다고 가정해 볼게요.
원한다면 이 밀도 행렬들의 볼록 조합을 취해서 가중 평균을 계산할 수 있어요.
하지만 그렇게 해서는 개별 상태가 무엇인지나 확률이 무엇인지 실제로 알 수 없어요.
대신 할 수 있는 것, 그리고 가끔 매우 유용한 것은, 화면에 나타난 형태의 밀도
행렬을 고려하는 거예요. 이건 두 시스템의 상태인데, 첫 번째 시스템은 각 대안에 대해 하나의 고전적 상태를 가지고,
m개의 곱 상태의 가중 평균을 취해요. 첫 번째 시스템의 상태는 항상 고전적이고,
본질적으로 두 번째 시스템에 대해 m가지 상태 중 어느 것인지를 표시해요.
이런 상태들을 왜 생각하고 싶은지 정확히 명확하지 않아도 괜찮아요. 이건 그냥 첫 번째 시스템이 항상 고전적이고
두 번째 시스템이 양자 상태에 있을 수 있는 유형의 상관관계의 예시예요.
세 번째 범주의 가능한 상관 상태는 소위 분리 가능한
상태의 집합이에요. 간단히 말하면, 이것들은 곱 상태들의 볼록 조합이고, 본질적으로 시스템 간의 상관관계가 고전적 상관관계인 양자 상태를 나타내요.
이런 상태를 생각하는 한 가지 방법은, 숫자 k에 대해 확률적 선택을 하고
그 다음 이 k 선택에 따라 달라질 수 있는 양자 상태에서 두 시스템을 독립적으로 준비하는 거예요.
이 형태의 상태에서 아마도 가장 흥미로운 건, 이게 수학적 용어로 얽힘을 정의하는 방식이라는 거예요.
특히 얽힘은 분리 가능성의 부재로 정의돼요. 따라서 밀도 행렬이 있고 그걸 이런 형태로 표현할 수 없다면,
정의에 의해 얽혀 있는 거예요. 4번 수업에서 이를 암시했고, 이제 조금 더 자세히 알아봤어요.
그런데 주어진 밀도 행렬이 얽힌 상태를 나타내는지 알아내는 건, 컴퓨터의 도움을 받아도 매우 어려울 수 있어요.
수학적으로나 계산적으로도 얽힘은 사실 꽤 복잡해요.
수업 시작 부분에서 밀도 행렬로 할 수 있는 아주 중요한 것을 언급했는데,
그건 다른 시스템과 상관되어 있고 얽혀 있을 수 있는 경우에도 시스템의 고립된 부분의 상태를 설명하는 것이에요.
이 맥락에서 축소 상태라는 용어가 자주 사용돼요. 간단한 예시로, ebit을 형성하는 개별 qubit들의 축소 상태를 계산할 거예요.
정확히 말하면, Alice와 Bob이 ebit을 공유하고,
Alice는 qubit A를, Bob은 qubit B를 가지고 있으며, 이 두 qubit이 함께 Φ+ 상태에 있다고 가정해 볼게요.
그리고 다룰 질문은 고립된 Alice의 qubit A의 상태가 무엇인지예요.
물론 Bob의 qubit에 대해서도 같은 질문을 할 수 있지만, 이 질문의 답을 알면 그 질문은 쉽게 답할 수 있어요.
이제 Alice의 qubit가 Bob의 qubit와 얽혀 있어서 고립된 A의 상태를 설명하거나 심지어 생각하는 것조차 금지될 수 있기 때문에
고립된 Alice의 qubit 상태를 설명할 수 없다고 말하고 싶을 수도 있어요.
하지만 이건 틀렸어요. A의 상태를 양자 상태 벡터로 설명할 수 없는 건 맞아요.
왜냐하면 곧 보게 되듯이 순수 상태가 아니기 때문이에요. 하지만 모든 시스템은 어느 순간이든 밀도 행렬로 설명될 수 있는 상태가 있어요.
다른 시스템과 얽혀 있든 아니든요. 사고 실험으로, 이 질문의 답이 뭔지 파악하는 데 도움을 주기 위해,
Bob이 자신의 qubit을 가지고 별들을 향해 여행을 떠나기로 결정해서 다시는 소식을 못 듣는다고 가정해 볼게요.
하지만 어느 시점에서 그가 자신의 qubit에 표준 기저 측정을 수행하기로 결정한다고 상상해 볼게요.
그럼 그가 두 가지 가능한 결과를 얻을 확률을 어떻게 계산하는지 알고 있어요. 또한 각 가능한 결과에 대해
A의 상태가 무엇이 될지도 알고 있어요. 그것들이 이 표에 요약되어 있어요. 특히 확률 1/2로
A는 0 상태에 남게 되고, 확률 1/2로 A는 1 상태에 남게 돼요.
따라서 수업 초반에 이야기한 것처럼, A는 완전히 혼합된 상태에 있게 돼요. 그래서 그게
우리 질문의 답이에요. 이제 Bob이 자신의 qubit를 측정하기로 결정했다는 사실에 의존하는 것 아니냐고 반론할 수도 있어요.
그가 그렇게 한다는 가정이 이 답으로 이어지는 이야기의 일부라는 것도 맞아요. 하지만
Bob이 측정하는 시점까지 수광년 거리에 있다면, 그가 하는 어떤 것도 Alice가 자신의 qubit에 수행하기로 결정한 어떤 실험에도 영향을 미칠 수 없어요.
그렇지 않으면 빛보다 빠른
통신이 가능해지기 때문이에요. 따라서 Bob이 측정을 하든 안 하든 Alice의 qubit는 완전히 혼합된 상태예요.
이 시점에서 명확히 해야 할 건, 축소 상태의 개념과 그것들이 정의되는 방식은 실제로 상대성 이론이나
빛보다 빠른 통신의 불가능성에 의존하지 않는다는 거예요. 이건 그냥 바라건대 직관적인 용어로 설명하는 방법이에요.
실제로는 수학적 정의가 있고, 잠시 후 더 일반적인 맥락에서 볼 거예요. 그 수학적 정의는 이 답과 일치하고,
우연히 빛보다 빠른 통신의 불가능성과도 일치해요. 그리고 양자 정보에서 알려진 것과 일치할 수 있는 다른 정의도 없어요.
이제 더 일반적인 맥락에서 축소 상태를 고려해 볼게요.
반드시 qubit일 필요는 없는 시스템 A와 B의 쌍이 있고, 양자 상태 벡터 ψ로 표현된 순수 상태에 함께 있다고 가정해 볼게요.
다시 시스템 A의 축소 상태에 집중할 거예요. 그리고 이를 위해 시스템 B의 고전적 상태들을 생각하는 게 유용할 거예요.
γ를 B의 이 고전적 상태 집합이라고 하죠. 예를 들어 시리즈의 2번 수업에서 이야기한 것처럼요.
γ의 각 b에 대해 벡터 φ_b의 고유한 컬렉션이 있어서 화면에 나타난 ψ의 식이 맞아요.
특히 이 벡터들에 대한 간단한 공식이 있어요. 단순히 벡터 ψ에 시스템 A에 해당하는 항등 행렬과
관심 있는 b에 대한 ⟨b|의 텐서 곱을 곱하면 돼요.
여기서 하는 건 기본적으로 시스템 B에 대한 표준 기저 측정을 수행하면 어떻게 되는지 계산할 준비를 하는 거예요.
여기서 하는 건 기본적으로 표준 기저 측정을 수행하면 어떻게 되는지 계산할 준비를 하는 거예요.
B에 대한 표준 기저 측정을 수행하는 경우예요. 다시 한 번, 이건 시리즈의 2번 수업에서 다뤘어요.
B에 대한 표준 기저 측정을 실제로 수행한다고 가정하면, 각 가능한 결과는
해당하는 벡터 φ_b의 유클리드 노름 제곱에 해당하는 확률로 나타나고, 특정 결과 b를 얻는 것에 조건을 걸면
벡터 φ_b를 정규화해서 결과로 나오는 a의 상태를 결정해요.
조금 전의 ebit 예시와 같은 추론을 따라, 밀도 행렬로서 a의 축소 상태에 대한
화면에 나타난 식을 얻어요. 그런데 분모의 노름 제곱은 정규화된 벡터를 켤레 전치와 곱할 때 나오는 거예요.
분모에 유클리드 노름이 두 번 들어가는데,
유클리드 노름 제곱이 상쇄되어 꽤 간단한
식이 남아요. 실제로 φ_b에 대한 공식을 모든 b에 대해 대입하면, 시작한 순수 상태의 밀도 행렬 설명, 즉 |ψ⟩⟨ψ|에 대한
시스템 a의 축소 상태에 대한 공식을 얻어요.
이게 복합 시스템 AB가 순수 상태 ψ에서 시작한다고 가정할 때 시스템 a의 축소 상태에 대한 공식이에요. 하지만 이 공식을 더 일반적으로 사용할 수도 있어요.
특히, ab의 상태가 어떤 밀도 행렬 ρ로 주어진다고 가정해 볼게요. 이게 어떤 양자 상태 벡터 ψ에 대해 |ψ⟩⟨ψ| 형태를 취할 수도 있지만,
반드시 그럴 필요는 없어요. 기본적으로 선형성에 의해, a의 축소 상태는 순수 상태에서 가졌던 것과 같은 공식으로 결정돼요.
단, |ψ⟩⟨ψ| 대신 원하는 어떤 밀도 행렬 ρ든 대입하면 돼요.
줄임 표기로, 이 축소 상태를 이 경우 사용하는 밀도 행렬 ρ의 이름으로 표기하는 게 꽤 일반적이에요.
단, 집중하는 시스템을 나타내는 첨자를 붙여요. 그래서 첨자 A가 있는 ρ는
복합 시스템이 상태 ρ에 있을 때 a의 축소 상태를 의미해요. 첨자 대신 위첨자를 사용하기도 해요.
기본적으로 개인 취향이고 같은 의미예요.
단순화를 위해 시스템 a에 집중했지만, 유사하게 시스템 B의 축소 상태도 얻을 수 있어요.
공식이 자연스러운 방식으로 조정되어요. 여기서 모든 게 대칭적이에요. 본질적으로 A와 B의 역할을 교환하는 거예요.
특히 이번에는 b가 아닌 a의 고전적 상태들에 대해 합산해요.
그리고 화면의 공식에서 a의 고전적 상태 집합을 시그마라고 가정해요.
이 모든 것은 세 개 이상의 시스템으로 꽤 직접적으로 일반화돼요. 예를 들어, 세 시스템 A, B, C가 있고 함께 밀도 행렬 ρ로 설명되는 상태에 있다면,
여기 나타난 공식으로 A와 B 쌍의 축소 상태를 얻을 수 있어요.
그리고 두 번째 공식은 세 번째 시스템만의 상태예요. 다른 조합도 고려하고
원하는 만큼 많은 시스템으로 일반화할 수 있어요. 합산은 항상 무시되는 시스템들의 고전적 상태 집합에 대해 이루어지고,
패턴은 항상 같아요. 시작한 밀도 행렬이 항등 행렬의 텐서 곱과 표준 기저 상태에 해당하는 브라와 켓 사이에 샌드위치되어 있어요.
수업을 마무리하면서, 방금 다룬 정의들에 대해 조금 더 이야기할게요.
축소 상태를 설명하는 밀도 행렬에 대한 연산에는 이름이 있는데, 부분 트레이스라고 해요. 두 시스템 A와 B에 대해,
B에 대한 부분 트레이스와 A에 대한 부분 트레이스는 화면에 정의된 것처럼이에요.
이건 조금 전에 본 공식들과 정확히 같아요. 이제 그것들을 ρ의 함수로 생각하고 이름을 붙이는 거예요.
이름은 트레이스처럼 보이는데, 어느 시스템이 제거되는지, 즉 어느 시스템의 고전적 상태 집합에 대해 합산하고
브라와 켓 사이에 샌드위치되는지를 알려주는 첨자가 있어요.
예를 들어 B에 대한 부분 트레이스를 취할 때, 즉 첫 번째 공식으로 설명되는 것처럼, B가 트레이스 아웃된다고 말하기도 해요.
A에 대해서도 마찬가지예요. 직관적으로 말하면, 시스템을 트레이스 아웃한다는 건 그냥 버리거나 무시한다는 의미예요.
이게 부분 트레이스를 정의하는 한 가지 방법이고, 동등한 또 다른 방법은 이 매핑들이
오른쪽에 나타난 공식들을 만족하는 고유한 선형 매핑이라고 말하는 거예요.
구체적으로, 두 행렬 M과 N의 텐서 곱이 있고 첫 번째 시스템에 대한 부분 트레이스를 수행하면,
얻는 건 첫 번째 행렬 M의 트레이스에 두 번째 행렬을 곱한 거예요.
조건은 두 번째 시스템을 트레이스 아웃할 때도 대칭적이에요. 부분 트레이스를 계산할 모든 행렬이 이런 텐서 곱은 아니지만,
모든 행렬은 텐서 곱의 선형 결합으로 표현될 수 있어요.
그리고 이 조건들과 함수들이 선형이라는 사실로부터 부분 트레이스를 결정할 수 있어요.
그래서 부분 트레이스라고 불리는 거예요. 이 동등한 정의는 꽤 유용할 수 있어요.
원래 공식 대신 자주 사용할 수 있기 때문이에요. 이를 설명하는 예시를 볼게요.
qubit 쌍 A가 화면에 나타난 밀도 행렬을 가진 상태에 있다고 가정해 볼게요.
이건 A가 각각 확률 1/2로 0 상태 또는 1 상태에 있는 상관 상태의 예시예요.
그래서 A를 고전적으로 생각할 수 있어요. A가 0 상태이면 B도 그렇고,
A가 1 상태이면 B는 플러스 상태예요. A의 축소 상태가 무엇인지 알고 싶다면
B를 트레이스 아웃해요. 동등한 정의의 두 번째 공식과 선형성을 사용하면
꽤 쉽게 계산할 수 있어요. 특히 |0⟩⟨0|의 트레이스는 1이고 |+⟩⟨+|의 트레이스도 1이에요.
따라서 텐서 인수들이 사라지고 완전히 혼합된 상태가 남아요. 비슷한 방식으로 A를 트레이스 아웃해서 B의 축소 상태도 계산할 수 있어요.
이번에는 첫 번째 텐서 인수에 대한 트레이스를 수행하기 때문에 동등한 정의의 첫 번째 공식을 사용해요.
그러면 1/2 × |0⟩⟨0| + 1/2 × |+⟩⟨+|가 남아요. 즉, 이전에 몇 번 등장했던 것과 같은 밀도 행렬이에요.
첫 번째 정의의 공식을 사용해도 정확히 같은 결과를 얻을 수 있어요. 하지만 이게 훨씬 더 쉬운 방법이에요.
이 모든 건 세 개 이상의 시스템으로 일반화되지만, 이 영상에서는 여기서 멈추고 여러분이 직접 고려해 보도록 남겨둘게요.
그리고 이것으로 이번 수업을 마치는데, 밀도 행렬을 소개하고 작동 방식의 기초를 설명했어요.
Bloch 구와 다양한 유형의 상관관계, 그리고 시스템의 축소 상태 개념도 다뤘어요.
다음 수업에서 함께 하시길 바라요. 다음 수업은 채널에 관한 것으로, 시스템에 대한 연산을 설명하는
밀도 행렬에서 밀도 행렬로의 선형 매핑이에요.
다음 수업에서는 channels에 대해 다룰 거예요. channels는 density matrix에서 density matrix로의 선형 매핑으로,
시스템에 대한 연산을 설명해요. 그때까지 안녕히 계세요.